I'm gonna try and show you how we can
obtain the the size of the Event Horizon
of a black hole with using no more than
School based maths
as a theoretical physicist it's what you
do when you first think about doing a
calculation you don't plunge straight in
and start in trying to solve some very
very complicated set of differential
equations what you tend to do initially
is you do what is called a dimensional
analysis you look at the units
and and you try and understand what what
do I expect the answer to look at in
terms of units and that often gives you
a real handle on what this solution
should look like it can be very powerful
when you're marking exams actually it's
a really good way of finding where a
student has made a mistake by looking
back and finding where the units don't
work out if you have an equation that
says x equals y then you don't think of
X as being meters and Y as being
kilograms you don't say this person's
six meters tall they must be the same as
this person over here who's six
kilograms you've got to have the same
units on either side of an equation and
it's as simple as that that's the basic
idea behind this but you can actually
make some real progress and we'll we'll
reach the black hole but on the way
we'll do Kepler's laws which is one of
the things we teach in second year uh
classical mechanics course as a solving
a rather complicated differential
equation we'll kind of get to the the
nub of it all right Ed and if I don't
like it you know where it's going to end
up in the confidential waste oh I'm
gonna put it in your confidential waste
bin
okay all right so where do we start I
guess we start with the title
dimensional analysis there's a nice blog
post that does something along this
Lines by a very good theoretical
physicist called Matt strassler Link in
the description so the idea is the
following right we we're going to use
units or in particular the consistency
of units to try and glean information
about a problem and it's likely solution
and it's remarkably powerful imagine
you've got the Sun and we've got the
earth going around the Sun okay and it's
got some typical radius R and it's got
some Associated period the time for it
to go around T and you can ask what's
the average velocity what would be the
possible equation that relates velocity
to the radius and the time
well everyone's going this is silly
right we know velocity is distance over
time
and so it's going to be some possible
number times the the radius divided by
the time and it can't be anything else
it can't be r squared divided by T
because that would have units of
kilometers squared divided by seconds it
wouldn't be a velocity so this is the
first example of a dimension dimensional
analysis giving me some information and
it turns out in almost all situations
that we deal with this number usually
becomes a number of order one
so we might not be bang on
because the the value will depend you
know if this was a circle that would be
2 pi right because the circumference
would be 2 pi r and if it was an ellipse
it would be something slightly different
but this number will typically be
something of order one and that's a
common thing that will come out it won't
be a billion or a billionth but now I
want to go and move on to Kepler right
Kepler's laws one of his most famous
laws relates the radius to the time with
this rather weird relationship that the
radius cubed
is proportional to the time squared or
if I divide by the amount it tells me
the radius Cube divided by the period
squared must be some constant and this
is true of all the planets you know
whether it's Mercury all the way out to
Uranus or Neptune or you didn't go for
Pluto I am going for Pluto I didn't know
whether you'd let me go for it but I am
going for Pluto's in there right this I
can't let go of Pluto I know Mike
doesn't is a bit more hard-nosed about
it and it's true of the moon going
around the earth as well so I thought
maybe we'll try and show this using what
I hope will be standard formula that
people will remember so the only thing I
want you to assume is our local hero
well one of our two Local Heroes we've
got George Green who's our really Local
Hero but we'll stop Manor is no more
than about 30 miles away from here so
Newton's hours so we'll assume Newton's
Laws if I have two objects let's call it
m and Little M and they're a distance R
apart Newton told us that the force of
attraction between those objects was
some constant mu is constant times Big M
times Little M over r squared so I can
rearrange this it's units that I'm going
to be interested in so I can rearrange
this right so this is just G is f r
squared over big n times little n but
there's one more equation what about the
what about F Well possibly the most
famous equation alongside E equals m c
squared is f equals m a we learned that
at score mass of the object times
acceleration but what's acceleration in
terms of units this becomes the mass I'm
going to use these square brackets here
to say we're talking about units that's
the mass and what's acceleration
kilometers per second squared for
example so it's distance over time
squared so now I can ask about the
dimension of G the units of G so I put
in the units here right so I get the
units of G and it becomes that says mass
times and then there's a length here but
there's also a length squared there from
the radius so we'll call that length
cubed divided by on the bottom here
we've got two masses so it's like a mass
squared and in fact one of this this
mask actually cancels these two little
m's are the same they cancel one of them
and that's why we've got that there and
then we've got the time squared from
here so this is times t squared so this
then becomes L cubed over and it's
actually this big Mass that's left and
it's times t squared and all of the
orbits that we're talking about are
going around the same object so this
object of mass m and so if I bring the
mass over to this side I have G times m
is actually L cubed over t squared and
the mass of the smaller object doesn't
even matter doesn't matter the mass of
the smaller object doesn't matter and
and so you know this is for example the
sun of mass m and so this is the the
relationship that comes from Kepler's
Law there'll be some number here because
when you've done the actual calculation
there'll be some numbers so what you
actually get is you know the the units
of G times m is actually going to be
some number times an L for us is the
radius and the time is the period so for
a given M then all the objects have the
same value of R cubed over t squared
that are going around it what we've
effectively done here is we've kind of
guessed Kepler's Law without solving
some equation which is telling me about
when you solve for Kepler's Law you've
got to solve for an angle that's going
around
and it's a differential equation you've
got to do changes of variables it's it's
quite a complicated thing but you've got
the the nub of the problem just just
there and so we've effectively guessed
Kepler's Law and we've done it from
dimensional analysis which I think's
nice and in fact we've got this unknown
number here and we've got G which we
haven't said what its value is but
actually it turns out if you're
interested in ratios of things then you
actually can still make a lot of
progress imagine that I've got the
following that instead I think of both
the earth going around the Sun but I'm
also thinking about the moon going
around the earth not necessarily got my
length scales very good here but the
Earth is going around the sun and the
moon is going around the earth and in
each case then I've got an equation that
something like says G times the mass of
the sun
is equal to some number
times the radius of the Earth to the Sun
cubed
divided by the period of the earth which
is a year of course squared
and we know what the radius is we've
also got G times the mass of the earth
is the same number times the radius of
the Moon to the Earth cubed divided by
the period of the Moon to the Earth with
what it's about a month right look what
happens if I divide one by the other
this unknown number cancels and the g
canceled and I'm left with a rather nice
formula which says that the mass of the
sun divided by the mass of the earth is
equal to and it's this ratio it's the
radius of the Earth Sun divided by the
Moon Earth cubed and then actually it's
this is the other way around it's the
period of the Moon earth divided by the
period of the Earth Sun squared well I
know these numbers right I can measure
these numbers and when you do it you get
that this is a number of order 325
000. in other words I've estimated the
mass of the Sun compared to the mass of
the Earth without knowing anything about
it you just had to know the radius I
just needed to know the radiuses and the
times okay and and you know I've just
used dimensional analysis for it knowing
the radiuses was a feat in itself though
no yeah I mean I'm being a bit flippant
yes it's not not easy to to determine
the the radius yeah no it's it's true
all right that's Kepler let me just
mention one that um is probably the most
famous equation of all time but just to
remind people that maybe you're pretty
liberal with most famous
well I'm waiting for my own there are
lots of most famous equations of all
time what's this most famous this one's
equals mc squared okay that is
but what I want to um
give a flavor for is that maybe people
when they first saw it might be really
surprised but perhaps they shouldn't
have been based on dimensional analysis
because I want to just remind people
that at school when we're learning about
energy we learn what kinetic energy is
right we learned that the kinetic energy
of an object of mass m moving with a
velocity V is equal to a half m v
squared most famous equation of all time
the most famous equation of all time and
but this now tells me immediately tells
me right that the units of energy here
because it's an equation the units have
got to be the same so we pretend we
don't know what the units of energy are
but we do know what the units of this
are we've got the mass so that's got a
unit of mass and we've got velocity
which has got units of length over time
so this has got units of L squared
divided by t squared and the question is
where the physics comes in is if I want
to get this relationship here equals mc
squared which of course has those units
right that's the point that I'm sort of
driving at we shouldn't be surprised
that it's of the form a mass times a
velocity squared
because that is the only thing that will
have the correct units now what we can
be surprised about is that speed of
light
and we might be surprised that the
number is one that we can't pluck out so
why isn't it so the speed of sound or
why isn't it you know some other speed
like the speed of of a you know a
traveling car or something why is that a
fundamental object because we think of
this as a very fundamental thing and
that of course is where Einstein's
Brilliance came in I mean if you're
gonna guess any speed that it was going
to be you surely you would guess the
speed of light because it's such a
fundamental thing in the universe
whereas everything like the cars and the
speed of sound a moving feasts yeah
you're very good okay all right I mean
I would I would have got that equal
since I would have figured that in no
time I mean you're bang on right I mean
Maxwell is the guy who was the one who
linked it to electromagnetism right he
realized when he was doing his
phenomenal equations it was this
fundamental speed emerging which was the
speed of light of massless particles so
it was clear that there was something in
there you know the natural thing as you
said linking it to light linking it to
electromagnetism it was actually
Einstein that really pinned down this
because he he demonstrated through his
theory of a special relativity that that
this was a this was a cosmic speed limit
that you just couldn't have information
going faster than this speed and so it
was an upper speed limit that was there
a natural one and so it was natural that
that Einstein would have this coming out
and in fact it's really neat in in his
paper it's a very short paper in 1905
was a phenomenal year right for Einstein
with some about six papers all of which
were Nobel prize winning type things
this was a short paper he wrote and and
what he basically said was if there is a
if you have an object with a mass m that
loses radiation the amount of radiation
it will lose in light is is this is its
mass will decrease by this amount I mean
and and in here of course is a
phenomenal statement about the the the
amount of energy for a small Mass
because we know in in units of meters
per second the speed of light is like
three times ten to the eight ten to the
nine so Square it you've got a factor of
10 to the 18 multiplying so the speed of
light wasn't quite such a big deal until
it equals MC yeah I think that's right I
think that I think Maxwell and and
others realized there was something
special about it through the
electromagnetism and it plays such a
crucial role but it was Einstein linking
it to space and time and the evolution
of space and time that that was the big
breakthrough are you getting us to Black
Ops black holes yeah yeah yeah I don't
mess around Brad
a bit
all right known for my uh rapid speed so
here we go black holes right so what am
I going to do are we going to do a big
course in general relativity no we're
going to do it via dimensional analysis
and we're going to do it via this skip
velocity one of the things we learn at
school calculator in the escape Velocity
how fast would a projectile have to be
sent from the earth in order for it to
go into orbit before before we did this
video we spent a great few minutes
looking at the polo films I guess like
everybody else that just arrived or all
three of us are plastered to the windows
look at them excuse me do you keep that
way you are anyway for sure and
and that had to have an escape last year
right and and so that's what we're going
to try and do and and from it end up
with a a remarkable close approximation
dimensionally perfectly correct to the
event horizon of a black hole okay
that's where we're going so let's
estimate it and we'll estimate it for an
object of mass m so that's going to be
like your Earth and of a radius R so
that's like the Earth orbit remember
earlier we saw the units of of Newton of
Newton's constant we said it's it's got
units of L cubed over mass times t
squared and that means that g m If I
multiply it by the mass has units of L
cubed over t squared you might think
what you're doing what you're playing at
I'm gonna get us to remember I'm doing
dimensional analysis I want to get this
to a velocity
that's what I want us to get to look if
I divide out by say the radius g m over
r a radius has got dimensions of length
I'm left on the right hand side with
something that's got dimensions of L
over t squared that's a velocity squared
I've got a velocity squared out of these
these combinations of the mass of the
object the radius of the objects and
Newton's constant so this is consistent
so so I can I can say oh there's some
relationship which I'll call the escape
Velocity which is some number which I
don't know but I'm estimating it it will
something be of order one times by this
combination g m over R okay let's look
at this just for a moment let's remind
ourselves what we're looking at we're
looking at an object of some mass m and
some radius R and we're asking there's
little U on your would-be rocket
desperate to get out and up and you will
need to know what's your escape velocity
to get Alpha now into orbit or out into
space one thing to notice is R decreases
for a given mass as I ring this object
this velocity increases so as R
decreases then it leads to ve increases
for a fixed that's important right for a
fixed mass and a natural question to ask
is what size would this object have to
be
in order for it to not allow light to go
instead of you it was light
how big would that be and this was and
light can only have one velocity right
yeah yeah yeah what about light I keep
the mass fixed and just shrink it down
light's got a velocity that we know so
we know that light has a velocity of C
so what we can do is we can rearrange
this equation here to write down what
the radius will be R is equal to some
number times g m over c squared and this
was first spotted by John Mitchell and
independently by LaPlace Pierre Simon
Simon is it now plus and the remarkable
thing is this was done in 1784 by John
Mitchell and 1796. so this is the radius
Beyond which light couldn't escape from
this object it's not a black hole
it's just an object that's you've just
found the radius for a given Mass that's
too big for anything that want to move
at the speed of light to get away it's a
black stone if you like or a
planet or something and you can sort of
put in some numbers right if I put in
the mass of the Earth this would give me
a radius of around two to three
centimeters golf ball type of size if it
was the mass of the Sun it would be the
radius of around a few kilometers around
two kilometers or so and below that size
like couldn't escape this remarkably
right this GM over
um us over c squared
is up to a factor of two
the size of the Event Horizon of What's
called the schwarztel black hole and it
was discovered by it's a solution to
Einstein's general theory of relativity
it's and it's an object that light
cannot escape from
if if light ends up anything that ends
up within that radius of the singularity
of the black hole
that light from it can't escape you can
emit as Photon and it will never be able
to escape and the actual size is just a
factor of two different so in Einstein's
general theory of relativity which you
know is about 1915 he found or actually
he didn't know about the existence of
this until Schwartz child found it that
you have a black hole with What's called
the schwarzed held radius which is 2 GM
over c squared where you know C is our
Universal speed limit so Ed if we crunch
the Earth down to less than you know two
or three centimeters yeah in in size it
wouldn't be a black hole yet no not this
one no yeah but it would but light
wouldn't be able to escape light
wouldn't be able to escape you could go
up to it and you'd be black
be careful wow
well I've calmed down a bit now Brady
and I think I can begin to talk about it